Dylan Curran is a technical consultant
of web developer he knows a lot about
the subject he just released a
terrifying report demonstrating just how
much information Google and Facebook
collect about you and the rest of their
users Dylan Curran joins us tonight
Dylan thanks a lot for coming on see me
up you do this stuff for a living you
thought you knew a lot about the level
of data collection by Facebook you
learned things you didn't know tell us
what you learned yes so I feel like a
lot of people in the tech industry had a
general idea of what was going on but
when I went in and actually looked at
the information I found a lot of things
that were totally unexpected so they
were recording as was said in the report
your actual phone records on your text
record so now your Facebook calls and
messages are your actual physical phone
records and then apart from that then I
went into Google and they were storing a
lot more information than I had
previously expected they were storing
search history as far back as there's an
age they had my location mapped back as
far as 2014 showing pretty much every
location I've been for the last four
years every day and with a timestamp
they have also they showed all of the
files and images I've ever downloaded
all the apps of every user searched for
they also showed my Google Fish
statistics like how many steps I've
walked workouts
yoga's all the ads I viewed and clicked
on all of my YouTube history and the
most disturbing thing was that they
actually showed you Google incognito
history so I tested this I went in
impressed Google incognito and they
actually kept the information it was in
the archive when I went to redownload it
so that means that when you think your
privately browsing Google is still
collecting a data which they they
included things that you thought you
deleted yes so I had my Google Drive
which is just cloud storage and I had a
lot of files on there that I wanted to
delete because they were personally
liable so that's right items such as you
know my CV my monthly budget a couple of
websites and code and an encryption key
and I had explicitly deleted those so
that there wouldn't be no threat of
those being stolen in the future but
then when I went into my archive those
bars were there
so Google we reach that's Google today
and about this and their response to
sensuous well everyone knows this you
know it's in the agate type in the terms
of use do you think everyone does know
this no absolutely not my tweets
wouldn't have received such unbelievable
attention if that was the case saying
everybody knows this is a carpet because
they're saying everybody knows this
because when you saw in the or when you
accept the terms and conditions of all
the apps you are technically signing
away your rights that information but
realistically nobody does read the terms
conditions cannot because not everybody
has the time to read those terms
conditions and not everybody is a
trained lawyer well that's right and
it's inherently dishonest if they tell
you you're deleting something but they
keep a record of it it's not deleted
that's a lie
and they should be held at Dylan thank
you thank you for that as terrifying but
interesting no raise thanks doctor